اهلا بكم تتارجح الهدنه في سوريا وتتلاحق
الاسئله بشان مال وقف اطلاق النار في
الوقت الذي يواصل فيه النظام السوري
مهاجمه مواقع المعارضه في غوطه دمشق
الشرقيه مدعوما من ميليشيات حزب الله
اللبناني تصعيد لافت لم ترى معه المعارضه
السوريه فائده من الحديث عن مسار جنف
التفاوضي ولا عن مسوده الدستور الروسي
المقترح مطالبه قبل ذلك بتثبيت واحترام
قرارات مفاوضات استانا يبقى السؤال اي فرص
بقيت لمفاوضات جنف في ساحه تتداعى فيها
الالتزامات ويتواصل فيها خلط
الاوراق الطريق الى جنف من اجل جوله اخرى
من المفاوضات السوريه ككل مره لن يكون
مفروشا بالورد ولا الموعد غير قابل
للتغيير فاحترام الهدنه المعلنه وهي شرط
من شروط المعارضه للحضور في تاريخ العش من
فبراير لا يبدو واردا في خطط نظام
دمشق هل ستنس ف معارك الغطه الشرقيه بكل
الجهود الدبلوماسيه السابقه واللاحقه من
اجل عقد جوله طال انتظارها تتحدث الاخبار
الوارده من الغطه الشرقيه عن تصاعد وتيره
الاشتباكات خلال الساعات الماضيه تقول
فصائل المعارضه المسلحه انها افشلت محاوله
النظام اقتحام الغوطه بعد هجوم من عده
محاور واضافت ان النظام يخوض معاركه بدعم
من حزب الله اللبناني تواصلت المواجهات
التي دارت في بلده حرز وحوش الظواهر وحوش
نصري الى ساعه متاخره من ليله السبت الاحد
وسط انباء عن وقوع ضحايا مدنيين في قصف
مدفعيه النظام مناطق سكنيه في مدينه حرستا
بالتزامن مع ذلك تتهم المعارضه والسكان
قواه النظام بخرق اتفاق ودي برده بريف
دمشق الشمالي الغربي يقول السكان ان
النظام قام بتفخيخ وتفجير جميع المنازل
المطله على منشاه نبع عين الفيجا فيما
يصفونها بخطه جديده لاستكمال سياسه
التغيير الديموغرافي ما الذي تريد دمشق
تغييره قبل موعد جنيف والاهم هل يمكنها
ذلك في ظل هدنه تعهدت روسيا الى جانب
ايران وتركيا بضمانها فعليا لم تغير شيئا
في مخططاتها منذ ال من ديسمبر الماضي
تاريخ اعلان الهدنه الساريه نظريا تصر
المعارضه السوريه على تثبيت وقف اطلاق
النار بشكل فعلي وك كامل قبل ان تحضر الى
جنف ماذا ستفعل موسكو وهي التي لن تقبل
بتاجيل اخر لجوله المفاوضات المرتقبه هل
ستضغط على النظام ليدن بعض الشيء ام ان
تامين دمشق وتطهير ريفها من المعارضه
وسكانها المحسوبين على المعارضه ملف بيد
الايرانيين وحزب الله اللبناني اي صفقه او
صفقات يجري التحضير لها لعقد المفاوضات
مهما كان الامر ثم من سيمثل من في حرب
فيها معارضات خارجيه وداخليه ودول تقاتل
على الارض السوريه وتتعهد في الوقت ذاته
بالعمل من اجل احلال السلام في البلد
المدمر مره اخرى البحث عن الحل السحري
للحرب السوريه في جينف يصطدم بعقبات كثيره
ويتعرض لنيران اكثر من جبهه مشتعله حتى
الان لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
اسطنبول الدكتور نصر الحريري عضو الهيئه
السياسيه للائتلاف السوري المعارض ومن
موسكو الدكتور جفور مير زويان المحلل في
الشؤون الدوليه في مجله اكسبرت الروسيه
اهلا بكم وابدا معك دكتور مير زويان في
موسكو اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار رعته اساسا
روسيا معها تركيا
وايران ما يجري اليوم في الغوطه الشرقيه
وقبلها في وادي
اين يضع هذا الاتفاق على وجه التحديد
اتفاق
استانا ان هذا الاتفاق طبعا برعايه مشتركه
من روسيا وتركيا
ويران وطبعا واتفاقيه صعبه للغايه الوصول
اليها واما فيما تعلق بالوضع حاليا في
سوريا جعل ما يحصل ما يحصل جعل التطبيق
الاتفاق صعبا فهناك مجموعات متقله كثيره
على الارض وطبعا هناك بعض المشاكل في
تطبيق الاتفاق لكن ما نفهمه نحن في روسيا
ونامل ان يفهمه شركاؤنا ان هذا الاتفاق هو
اساس لكل حل مستقبلي ستكون طبعا هناك بعض
المشاكل في التطبيق وف نقول ذلك لكن هذا
افضل اتفاق يمكن ان نتوصل اليه حاليا في
سوريا بما يخص الوضع ككل وما يخص كل تعقد
تعقيد الوضع وكما تعلمون كان هناك محادثات
في ع عفوا سيد دكتور مرزيان يعني تقول ما
يحدث جعل تطبيق هذا الاتفاق صعبا لكنه لكن
المعارضه ملتزمه به المعارضه ما زالت حتى
الساعه تطبق هذا الاتفاق من يخرق الاتفاق
هو النظام يعني استمرار النظام على هذا
النهج على مراه ومسمع من الدول الراعيه
لهذا الاتفاق التي لم تحرك ساكنا اي رسائل
او انطباعات قد
يعطي مع كل احترامي لا استطيع القول مره
اخرى اقول مع كل احترامي لا يمكن القول ان
قوات الثوار يحترمون الاتفاق وقوات النظام
لا يفعلون هذه حرب اذا كان هناك
اصطدامات فهذا يعني ان لا هناك اي طرف
يحترم وقف الاطلاق لا النظام ولا المعارضه
او ما نتحدث عليه مدى عدم تطبيق او احترام
الاتفاق حاليا هناك فقط بعض المشاكل
الصغيره في التطبيق او بعض الاماكن
المحدوده التي لا ينفذ فيها الاتفاق ولكن
بشكل عام نشاهد
ان انه هذا الاتفاق يحترم من قبل الطرفين
وهذا من حسن الحظ الدكتور نصر الحريري
يعني مشاكل صغيره في التطبيق كما وصفها
الدكتور
مرزيان من الموسكو من موسكو يعني امام هذه
الخروقات التي بات واضحا بانها تستغل
الوقت ربما لتحقيق وقائع جديده على الارض
ماذا ستفعل المعارضه ما هي خيارات
المعارضه واوراق المعارضه التي يمكن ان
تستخدمها
الان
يعني التعرض لبعض القضايا المتعلقه
بالخروقات نحن لا لا نتحدث عن خروقات
صغيره خروقات يتم فيها استخدام كل انواع
الاسلحه الجويه والارضيه فيها استهداف
للمناطق السكنيه موجوده على الاقل في سبع
محافظات سوريه يشارك فيها قوات متعدده ما
تبقى من قوات النظام القوات الايرانيه
والمليشيات التابعه لها اضافه الى الطيران
الروسي وعدد هذه الخروقات بالمئات وهناك
عمليات عسكريه بريه كبرى تمت في وادي برده
نموذجا والان تستمر في الغوطه الشرقيه
والتركيز طبعا على مدينه دمشق وما يحيط
بمدينه دمشق سواء من خلال عمليات عسكريه
مفتوحه او محاولات الهدن كما يتم في
الاحياء الجنوبيه لمدينه دمشق طبعا اليوم
يعني عمر هذا الاتفاق شهر وعده ايام
الصراحه خلال هذا الشهر وفي سجل حافل من
عدم الالتزام كنا امام يعني خيارين او
امام احتمالين الاحتمال الاول انه ت توجد
بعض المؤشرات الى ان الروس وعلى الرغم من
انهم الداعم الاكبر للنظام والذي انقذوا
سقوط دمشق كما قال لافف قبل فتره انه اذا
لو لم نتدخل لسقطت دمشق خلال اسبوعين الا
ثلاث اسابيع ان هؤلاء
الداعمين يعني ظاهر ان ليس لديهم قرار او
اثر قوي على الارض ومن يتنفذ بالقرار
ويشاغلك
الاتفاقيه هي الميليشيات الايرانيه التي
ليست لها مصلحه وايران طبعا بنجاح اي
مفاوضات ميدانيه او انسانيه او سياسيه لان
هذا سيكون بالضروره نجاح هذه المفاوضات
سيكون بالضروره ليس لصالح النظام وليس
لصالح الم تحليل لما يحدث على الارض تحليل
واضح دكتور لما يحدث على الارض الان نتحدث
عن خيارات المعارضه فيما يتعلق بهذه
الوقائع الجديده على الارض ماذا امامكم
لان تفعل المعارضه امام كل
هذه المواجهه المعارك المستمره الهجمات
المستمره من قبل النظام والمواقف الم
معلنه التي تحدثت عنها للدول الراعيه
للاتفاق يعني هذا يمكن الحديث عنه في
نقطتين النقطه الاولى من داخل الاتفاقيه
يحق لكل طرف تتم بحقه الخروقات ان يدافع
عن نفسه بالطريقه التي يراها ضروريه وضمن
الحد يعني الذي يدفع الخطر عن نفسه وطبعا
اذا زادت هذه الخروقات يعني يصبح لهذه
الاتفاقيه كيف ذلك كيف ذلك هذا هذا يتم
بالرد على بالرد على الخروقات في الاماكن
التي يقوم بها النظام بخرقها او عبر يعني
التخطيط لعمليات عسكريه في مناطق اخرى
تضغط على النظام من اجل الالتزام بهذه
الخروقات نقطه الضعف بهذه القضيه هو سيطره
او يعني تركيز النظام على المناطق البعيده
عن سيطره المعارضه او المحاصره ضمن يعني
جيوب تحيط بها قوات النظام والمليشيات
الايرانيه من كل جهه فبالتالي هناك مناطق
اخرى تسبب يعني الما للنظام فيما لو تم
استهدافها اها اما عن العمل خارج
الاتفاقيه هو ان يكون هناك انهيار واضح
لهذه الاتفاقيه وانا لا اشك في ذلك يعني
او يعني لا استبعد عفوا ذلك اليوم جميع
الفصائل تنتظر اجتماع استانه يوم غد يوم
خمسه وست شهر الذي يفترض ان يناقش كل هذه
القضايا وهناك كذلك انزعاج كبير من الطرف
التركي الضامن لانه حتى هذه اللحظه لا يرى
اي التزام وهناك نقاط على جدول اعمال
الاجتماع غدا اولها تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
ونح نحن قدمنا وثيقه واضحه للاليات وهناك
كذلك حول الاجراءات الانسانيه اذا لم يتم
تنفيذ على الاقل جزء من هذه القضايا اعتقد
اعتقد انه اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق النار لن
يكون لها اي وجود بعد على الارض بعد هذا
الاجتماع دكتور مر زويان احترام الهدنه
المعلنه هو ش شرط من شروط المعارضه لحضور
مفاوضات 20 فبراير يعني ماذا ستفعل موسكو
برايك فيما لو استمر النظام على حاله
واستمرت معارضه في رفضها الحضور فيما لو
لم يتوقف
النار معارضه ان تذهب او لا تذهب الى جنيف
ان تذهب او لا تذهب الى استان ولكن علينا
ان نفهم انه في هذا الوضع المعارضه ليس
امامها من
خيار طبعا نحن نقسم المعارضه الى الاشخاص
ال يقاتلون في يزفون بحياتهم والذين
يجلسون يعيشون في اوروبا وتركيا ويحصلون
على اموال من تركيا ولا يقاتلون هذا الجزء
الثاني من المعارضه الذين يكسبون الاموال
من تركيا لا يحتاجون السلام ولا يريدونه
ونحن نفهم ذلك ولكن اولئك الذين يقاتلون
على العارض
س من خيار ماذا تقصد بهذا الكلام دكتور
مرزان دكتور ماذا تقصد بان المعارضه ل
امامها من خيار نحن نعلم بان موسكو رفضت
ان يكون هناك تاجيل اخر المعارضه متمسكه
بموقفها ماذا تعني بان المعارضه لا خيارات
امامها انا اود ان اشرح لكم ذلك ان هذه
المعارضه المعارضه التي تقات على الارض
حقلا على الارض وهم جزء من الحرب الجاريه
في سوريا ليس لديها من اي خيار اخر لان
شاهد ان الاستراتيجيه ق تغيرت في سوريا
وترك امريكا وتركيا لم يعدوا يدعمونهم او
لن يدعمونهم في المستقبل وبالتالي ليس
اماهم سوى خيار واحد الا هو التفاوض مع
السيد الاسد واتفاق مع الاسد ربما اتفاقيه
السلام ستعتمد على المشروع الروسي لكتابه
الدستور الجديد او ربما يقدمون مشروعا
خاصا بهم
للدستور
لكن وضع اليوم ان المعارضه بدات تخسر
الحرب في سوريا واذا خسرت الحرب ف طبعا
يكون امام فقط خيار خيارين او اما التفاوض
مع الفائز
المنتصر لتوصل الى شروط محترمه مقبوله
والثانيه الموت واذا ارادت المعارضه ان
تختار الخيار الثاني الموت فهذا خيارهم هم
لهم الحق في ذلك نعم دكتور عفوا عفوا على
مقاطعتك فقط لضيق الوقت دكتور نصر الحريري
لا خيار امام المعارضه الان انتم يعني وفد
المعارضه اتخذ موقفا على ما يبدو واعلن
انكم او اعلنتم انكم لن تشاركوا في هذه
المفاوضات ما لم يتم تثبيت وقف اطلاق
النار هذا الكلام سمعنا ما يشبهه
قبل مفاوضات استانا وايضا اثناء معارك
وادي برده هل فعلا لا خيار امامكم
باختصار يعني يعني بدايه بس يفترض انه ها
العمليه تختلف عن العمليات الماضيه من
ناحيه وجود انخراط مباشر لروسيا لاول مره
في العمليه السياسيه المفترضه اضافه الى
وجود يعني دوله من اهم الدول الداعمه
للقضيه السوريه اليوم الحديث ليس عن والله
وجود خيار فقط للذهاب هل هناك فرصه لنجاح
هذه المفاوضات اذا كانت روسيا والمحلل
يعكس وجهه نظر روسيا بانه لا يوجد خيار
الا التفاوض مع الفائز وانه سيذهب الى
جنيف لاعاده ده تلميع ووجود بشار الاسد
فاعتقد انه نحن نتحدث عن فشل عمليه في
مقدماتها لا يمكن طبعا لا يمكن ان يتخيل
انه معركه حلب او الاحداث التي تجري على
الارض هي نهايه المعركه في سوريا ولو
استطاعت روسيا بالفعل ان تحسم المعركه
عسكريا لم تكن مضطره الى التفاوض مع الشعب
السوري لان وجود الملف على ما هو عليه
يعكس حاله من القتال والصراع الدائم الذي
لن تهدا فيه روسيا ولن تهدا فيه عديد
الدول التي تشارك في هذا المحل وعندما
لجات روسيا الى العمليه التفاوضيه لجات
لانها تعتبر انه هذا الخيار هو الاسلم
للوصول الى حاله الاستقرار في سوريا طبعا
الخيارات هي خيارات كثيره بيد الشعب
السوري المعركه حتى هذه اللحظه ستبقى
مستمره ضد النظام على الرغم من تمسكنا
الاستراتيجي بالحل السياسي الذي يحقق
طموحات الشعب السوري ورحيل بشار الاسد لا
اعاده هيكله بشار الاسد شكرا لك من
اسطنبول الدكتور نصر الحريري عضو الهيئه
السياسيه الائتلاف السوري المعارض ومن
موسكو الدكتور جفور مرزيان محلل الشؤون
الدوليه في مجله اكسبرت
الروسيه